Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain the German satirical comedy film
called “Look Who’s Back.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The beginning of the movie is set somewhere during
the second world war in Berlin. The Fuhrer Hitler
is with a behaviour coach named Keppl. Hitler
expresses his disagreement with the gesture of
people's greeting to Keppl. He complains that
though the Nazi salute is out-fashioned, people
need to at least raise their hands up to the wrist
and show respect. Then, he narrates that he has
done everything possible by a human to destroy
the foundations of the enemy who desecrated their
soil. He finds German's existence incomprehensible
and finds it alarming that he is here too.
In the following scene, he wakes up on the ground
somewhere in a forest. While looking up to the
sky, he sees that the enemy aircrafts are missing
and guesses that they might have taken some rest.
Suddenly, a ball comes bouncing towards him and
stops just at his side. He raises himself and
heads towards a building past the bush. He is then
approached by three young kids who question him
if he is okay. Hitler looks at them and
thinks that they are the future of the
nation. He then asks them the way to the street.
In that instant, a reporter, Fabian Sawatzki,
is filming the kids on his camera. Hitler is
seen on the far side of the screen. He picks
up his army cap and says to himself that he should
go to the Fuhrer Bunker. Hitler gets to the street
and gets amazed at people riding monowheel bikes.
He finds people capturing him in their camera and
expresses that though the rubble went, people have
gone mad. Then, he feels a modern car by his hand
and questions himself if he fell in a coma and
missed the victory. He realises that he is not
aware of his situation totally and alerts himself
to collect more information. Then, he asks a man
about the location of Chancellery but the person
instead asks him for a picture. He gets disturbed
by the camera's flashes as people come near him
and take photos in turns. Confused by the unusual
events around him, he concludes something went
out of hand in the place. As Hitler walks away,
he finds a woman speaking in German on her phone.
He comes closer and asks her about the current
date, but the woman gets terrified and sprays his
eyes. Hitler cries in pain as his eyes get reddish
and his vision gets blurred. He stumbles and
walks to a newspaper shop nearby. He gets
shocked to see the date October 3, 2014, written
on the paper and falls to the ground at once.
Somewhere else, the boss of a TV station,
Karrner, praises Mr. Christoph Sensenbrink for his
excellent job as the deputy's head. He proposes
a higher solution but instead announces another
worker named Miss Katja Bellini as the managing
director. Due to this, Christoph gets shocked and
dissatisfied. He comes to his office and vents his
anger out at a struggling filmmaker named Fabian.
Despite Fabian’s best attempts to convince his
boss, he gets fired and thrown out by the guards.
Some time later, Hitler wakes up at the news shop
and asks the owner about the date. He confirms
that it is in fact 2014. A confused Hitler
questions if the shopkeeper has kidnapped him
and suspects if all this is a trick play of the
enemy's secret service. He threatens to kill the
shopkeeper if he is working for the enemy but the
shopkeeper gives him a bar of chocolate instead.
Hitler opens it after quite a struggle and sniffs
it. He declares it as industrially pressed grain
and questions the shopkeeper if there is still a
shortage of bread. The shopkeeper asks Hitler if
they are filming a documentary somewhere nearby,
mistaking him for an actor. The shopkeeper then
says that he looks exactly like the Fuhrer to
which Hitler replies that he is the Fuhrer.
After that, Hitler sees the Turkish newspaper and
asks if the shopkeeper has Sturmer or Panzerbar.
The shopkeeper says that he has more Turkish
customers. Hitler gets astonished at the presence
of Turkish people in Berlin. He then starts
collecting information from the newspaper.
While reading it, he assumes that he didn’t win
the war in the past and Germany was given to the
hands of clumsy women having the charisma of a wet
noodle. He further laments the existence of Poland
and concludes the war to be a total waste.
Meanwhile, Fabian looks upon his video reporting
about soccer and sobs, sad at the fact that he
was fired. His mother calms him and asks him to
pause the video, noticing Hitler behind. Fabian
is amused at the discovery of a person who looks
so similar to Hitler. Back in the shop, the
shopkeeper asks Hitler to keep the newspaper aside
and stand outside. Hitler grudges at being asked
to work. The shopkeeper suggests Hitler clean his
clothes, for they are stinking. He then goes
to a laundry place and asks them to clean his
uniform. Hitler asks if they have another
uniform since he cannot walk away naked.
Next, we see Hitler walking to the news
seller with jeans and a sweater on. Fabian,
on the other hand, has somehow managed to find him
and is waiting for him in the shop. After getting
a look at Hitler, he is amazed at his appearance.
Fabian asks Hitler if he can film him as he
marches through modern Germany. Hitler agrees with
the idea. Fabian takes up some cash and a car from
his mother and starts his journey with Hitler.
The two end up in a hotel where Hitler gets
amused at seeing the television. He then decides
to talk about Politics in Fabian's presentation.
He goes to places asking people regarding their
views on politics. After the interviews, he finds
that there was minimal impact of democracy upon
people during his absence. He inspects discontent
and suppressed anger in people which reminds him
of the 1930s, when people had similar views but
lacked the term 'Political disenchantment'.
People tell Hitler about the problem of
immigrants in the country making Hitler push
his idea that mixing the races doesn't work.
Later, Fabian asks Hitler the source of his
unique mustache. Hitler replies that he cut his
mustache to the shape to fit a gas mask. A while
later, the two end up in a farm where Hitler gets
bit by a dog. He is enraged and shoots at the
animal. Fabian scolds him and seizes the gun.
As the tour goes on, Fabian eventually runs out
of cash. But he thinks of a plan and convinces
the passers to have their sketches drawn by
Hitler. Hitler draws sarcastic pictures which
people find funny and pay for it. They continue
their trip after collecting enough money.
Back in town, Fabian shows a clip of Hitler to
Christoph. The video has a lot of views as Fabian
had uploaded it on the internet. Christoph
is impressed by the large number of views
in the video. He asks Fabian for Hitler’s
name and contact number. After meeting him,
Christoph suspects Hitler to be a lunatic and
asks Fabian to take him away from the office.
Before leaving, Hitler enters the director’s
office and asks her to save Germany together
with him. Interested at the idea,
Bellini asks him about the plan.
She quickly asks her assistant to prepare a proper
TV format for broadcasting the Fuhrer on listening
to Hitler's idea. Fabian then threatens Christoph
to give him his job back or else he will take
Hitler away. On hearing this, Christoph makes him
a kitchen boy promising to promote him when a new
editorial post opens up. Some time later, Hitler
is given a table in the TV studio. Christoph
calls for Kromeier to help Hitler with computer
use. Hitler recalls the computers of his days and
labels the invention to be one of the greatest.
Kromeier tries to sign up Hitler to mail but
informs him that his name is already taken. Hitler
grunts for others stealing his name and tells her
to use 'New Reichs Chancellery' as he liked it.
Christoph plans to put Hitler on a live comedy
show called Whoa Dude! He is still salty
because Bellini got a promotion instead of him
and intends to create trouble for her. He
intends to bring racism to the debate through
sarcastic jokes on Jews and throw out Hitler.
The show starts, and Witzigman, the host, calls
for Hitler on the stage. The audience gossips
about Hitler's appearance but when Hitler gazes
at the audience, the hall gets completely silent.
Hitler soon breaks the silence but does not read
out the lines as scripted. He explains that he
is to tell a joke about immigrants but he is
not going to do so. He says that a TV is a great
invention of the human, but the shows broadcasted
are nonsense. He sheds light on problems like
poverty and unemployment and forecasts that the
people of the country are heading towards the
abyss without noticing it. Hitler vows to fight
against the TV not only up to the broadcast
of the abyss but also until he succeeds in
overcoming them. Everyone likes the idea and
claps for him. Seeing Hitler's popularity,
the host Witzigman gets envious. Bellini asks
Christoph to broadcast Hitler in every show.
Christoph is distressed because of the failure of
his plan. In the following scene, we see Hitler
give interviews on numerous TV shows and share
that his motive is to make Germany great again.
His popularity grows immensely and he meets
several people and party leaders. He starts
charming them all by sharing his ideas. One
day, Hitler and Fabian visit NPD headquarters
in Berlin. He calls for Ulf Birne, the Federal
Chairman of NPD and asks him what his cause
has achieved so far. Hitler belittles him
and says that they have wasted enough time,
and the movement is taken aback
by decades due to their words.
Christoph gets excited and happy when the cops
and District Attorney (DA) appear at the TV
studio. They explain that they are here for a
complaint of charging violation of hate laws.
Bellini asks what they are to do then. Quickly,
Christoph pops that they might need to cancel the
Fuhrer show. The DA says that they can keep the
broadcasting on. Bellini takes a sigh of relief
while Christoph fakes his smile.
After the DA leaves, Kromeier hands
over a letter to Christoph stating the payment
of the dog which Hitler had shot earlier in
his trip. Christoph receives the letter happily
believing it might be a way to cause trouble.
Next, Hitler is put to a TV program where he
is asked direct questions about his different
roles in the war. Hitler responds that he wants to
reach out to people but the interviewer tells him
that all his deeds cannot be justified. He shows
him the clip of him shooting the dog. The video
disturbes the audience. Hitler is angered and
threatens him that he would do the same to
him. He further says that he will turn their
studio into a parking lot for tanks. Christoph
gets happier seeing people's negative responses.
After the disastrous interview, Bellini is fired,
and Christoph is appointed as the new manager.
After that, Hitler goes to Fabian's house and
starts living with him. He expresses amusement at
the path taken by destiny and starts to write his
second book. The book soon hits the market.
Three months later, at the TV studio,
everyone sits in a meeting where the massive loss
that the company has gone through is discussed.
Christoph believes that Witzigmann's show will
put them back on track, but one employee informs
him that he has quit his job. Christoph gets
tensed and gets mad at the selected employees
for losing the show. One of the staff suggests
getting Hitler back which interests Christoph.
He looks for Hitler again and offers Fabian
that he will invest a million in the film
that Fabian and Hitler are shooting if they in
return let them broadcast the movie on their TV.
Hitler and Fabian come to Kromeier's house
where Kromeier's grandmother identifies Hitler.
She claims that Hitler gassed all the people up
and killed them. She calls him a criminal and
shouts him to get out. In the car, Hitler shares
that he is surprised at Kromeier being a Jew.
He starts to belittle jews calling them
less of humans. Fabian gets disappointed
at Hitler's actions and his words.
Back in the set, Fabian gets Hitler to
replay how he got to the place. He asks Hitler
what happened before the ball came rolling to
him in the woods but Hitler cannot remember
it. Later at night, he walks out of the set
and is surrounded by some thugs. They call him the
reason to take Germany back and give him a hard
blow on his face. As Hitler opens his eyes, he
finds himself in a hospital in front of Bellini.
At the same time, Fabian looks over the footage of
the video he captured about the boys and soccer.
He looks closely at it and finds Hitler rose
from where he was lying. Fabian gets amazed at
what happened before it. He quickly goes to
the place and finds a board at the location
stating the Historical location of
‘Fuhrer Bunker’. Fabian rushes to the
hospital but doesn't find Hitler. Bellini
says that he is headed to the shooting set.
Fabian reveals that he is the real Adolf Hitler
but Bellini does not believe him. Fabian acts mad
and tries to explain his theory hysterically.
The guards try to catch him, but he flees.
Fabian then reaches the set and aims a gun
at Hitler. When asked about his identity,
Hitler explains that he never claimed to be anyone
else. Fabian says that Hitler is fooling people
with his propaganda to which Hitler replies that
people elected a leader who shared his whole idea
openly in 1933. Fabian takes Hitler to the top
of a building with his gun. He corners Hitler
and declares him to be a monster. Hitler, inturn
claps back saying that ordinary people elected an
extraordinary man and entrusted the fate of the
country to him. He explains that people chose him
because they bear the same values in their inner
hearts. An enraged Fabian shoots Hitler, making
him fall down the building, onto the street.
Soon, Fabian hears Hitler’s voice, who says that
no German can get rid of him. And Hitler, who was
just thrown down, appears right behind it again.
Just then, Bellina calls for a cut in the
studio, and everyone cheers for the shoot.Turns
out that it was just a film shoot and a
random actor was playing the role of Fabian.
Hitler then asks everyone to remember the
comrades who could not be with them.
Somewhere else, Kromeier is sobbing seeing
Fabian through a hole in the mental ward.
Hitler and Bellina are busy giving autographs
and interviews to people after the film booms.
As they pass by a car, the people
on the street seem fond of Hitler
and greet him with respect.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.